[ Applause ]
MARLEY: Thank you.
And hello.
Today I'll be talking to you about the case
for augmented reality on the web.
I'm Marley Rafson.
I'm a software engineer at Google on the web
XR team.
My Twitter handle is mprafson.
Love to talk letter.
The two things today with the web and augmented
reality.
I believe that the combination of these two
things, the whole is greater than the sum
of its parts situation.
I think that the web will gain from augmented
reality, and things that augmented reality
will certainly gain from the web.
So, to begin, let's start by getting everyone
on the same page and let's define augmented
reality.
It's the mixing of computergenerated content
with the real world.
To me, we can now add contextualized information
into the world around us.
So, for example, you're trying to make a coffee
at the coffee machine, and you have the instructions
overlaid on top of the coffee machine.
And implication of augmented reality is you
can interact with 3D content in a 3D space.
So, the canonical example would be you're
trying to buy a piece of furniture and you're
able to put it into your room before you buy
it.
Let's look at what augmented reality looks
like today.
Today this is smartphone AR.
This is run using a smart phone and basically
has some understanding of the world around
it allowing virtual content to interact with
that world too.
We have augmented reality on headsets.
Your hands would be free, and you would be
free to interact with the content using your
hands.
And the third example that I think is less
talked about, but I find compelling is audiobased
augmented reality.
You're seeing Bose frames.
It's a pair of sunglasses that have speakers
that shoot audio into your ears.
With this example, with audio AR, you would
have that experience where you're at a coffee
machine and you don't know what to do.
But instead of seeing the information, it's
read off to you.
And it I would also like to say if you hear
me say AR, that's just short for augmented
reality.
So, this talk, as I mentioned, it's also about
the web.
Let's talk about where those two things intersect.
That's what we'll call the immersive web.
And the immersive web is the use of augmented
reality, virtual reality and other 3D technologies
on the web.
It's this whole spectrum of things.
It can be more augmented reality than virtual
reality and doesn't quite matter.
And you'll hear me say XR.
And that really just stands for wild card
reality.
So, it could be virtual, it could be augmented
reality and some combination of the two.
So, today what the immersive web looks like
is something like this.
We have seen progressive enhancements of sites
we use every day.
The left two examples, Facebook 3D posts and
they're incorporated directly into the newsfeed.
So, that first example is a 3D model that
you can interact with on the newsfeed.
The second is using portrait mode depth information
to delightfully play with these photos with
a bit of depth added.
And the third example is from Wikipedia who
about a year ago started supporting 3D models
in their articles.
So, if you're not a large company and you
don't have a whole engineering team dedicated
to building this model viewing experience,
there's a solution to that now.
So, recently Google, a team at Google open
sourced a web component for viewing models.
It's called Model viewer.
It's fantastic.
Using HTML, you can add into your side around
it.
That's an example with the astronaut which
we know and love.
And something that's great about the modelviewer
team is they're thinking about accessibility
early.
So, they've already incorporated alt text
into the component.
So, let's say you have these 3D models on
your website.
How do you actually get it into augmented
reality?
So, right now what we've seen is implementations
of native system viewers that allow for augmented
reality.
This is not running in a web browser, but
this is slick and tight integration with the
web.
So, you would have this search result, so
it's integrated into search with Google.
So, you can tap the button and then it intents
into this native viewer and then you can place
it in augmented reality is the same exists
on iOS and it's similarly intense.
And so, what I just said there was that we're
using native viewers to do augmented reality.
But we would like to do that in the browser
itself.
That's where the WebXR device API comes in.
It exposes lowlevel sensory information.
So, the camera pose, if you can place an object
on the floor.
And that's under development.
It's open so we can all contribute to it.
And you can find that on GitHub.
And with those examples that I just shared,
that's all talking about bringing immersive
technologies into the web.
But we can also bring the web into immersive
technologies.
Two examples of XR browsers.
And you will see the Helio browser placing
images into the world around you and then
Firefox Reality, which is a VR browser.
So, I think the immersive web today is fantastic.
I think it's adding information, it's making
it more delightful to browse the web.
But when we're developing these technologies,
it's important to see where we're going next
and to start thinking about that earlier rather
than later.
So, when I think about a future of augmented
reality, I start by thinking about how can
this assist me?
So, I think about maybe I'm leaving work one
day and I'm wearing these lightweight AR goggles,
I'm walking down the street.
I'm looking for dinner.
So, as I look at the restaurants on the street,
I'm seeing Yelp data populating with the stars
rating and the types of menu.
And maybe I also want to see photos of the
food.
So, Instagram information's coming too.
And I like Pokemon.
So, maybe while I'm doing all of this, I'm
catching Pokemon, playing Pokemon Go.
And when I get to the train station, I'll
have information populated for me telling
me which train to take so I can get home fastest.
And as I mentioned earlier, I probably don't
want to be restricted to doing this on just
one headset.
Maybe I want headphones another day from a
different company.
Who knows?
Maybe I just want to use my smartphone.
So, when I'm thinking of this vision of augmented
reality going forward, I start to see some
interesting things and patterns that I would
like to call out here.
So, the first is that is inherently uses web
content.
I want access to all the things that I already
use when I'm browsing the web.
Another thing is it's this really interesting
composition of different types of information.
So, that could be models or 2D pages.
And we're going to have to interact with them
in a way that's esthetic and delightful and
still makes me want to use it.
And onethird trend that I start to see it
we're really interacting with the world around
us.
I could be places information on to a building
or on to a tree or on passing by cars.
And so, when I start to think about this vision
that I want and where we are today, which
is mostly placing 3D models, I think there
is a lot of work to go.
And where I see a lot of that work coming
into play is with a user agent.
So, the definition from W3C of a user agent
is a user agent is any software that retrieves,
renders and facilitates end user interaction
with web content.
So, today that's usually just your browser.
So, you get a lot of things when you're browsing
using any of the modern browsers.
It could be Chrome, it could be Firefox.
It helps you do safe browsing.
It renders the HTML pages for you and things
like that.
So, to understand how a user agent will play
out with this added dimension for augmented
reality, let's start to break down this definition
of user agent.
So, I'll go in reverse order.
Start with a user agent facilitates end user
interaction with web content.
So, what I believe is that the user should
always be in control of how information is
presented to them.
So, on a modern web browser, that's preferences
like default text sizing.
That's contrast ratios.
And Chrome extensions and things like that.
But when you think about augmented reality,
we have this whole new dimension.
It's really immersive.
It's, you know?
And so, we need to start to think about other
ways that we want to have safe browsing and
we want the user to be in control.
One example, think about physical proximity.
You have content that's being rendered possibly
close to you and I should be able to say I'm
not comfortable with anything rendering closer
than 5 meters away from me.
Or I think it's compelling to think about
this in terms of sound.
I probably would never want to allow someone
to whisper into my ear as I'm walking down
the street.
so, a lot of these considerations come into
play when we're talking about augmented reality.
And in order to accommodate these things for
the years, we're going to need an intervention
point for the information.
So, the user agent knows what's being asked
of it to do this.
If we think of declarative content that we
know and love, that would be HTML and CSS.
I see this future where there's declarative
content that you're able to add into the world
around you so you could specify things like
I would like float left and pin to a building.
Or you could say, I want the depth to be 5
meters from the user.
But it's up to the user agent to decide whether
or not it can actually honor that request.
And it's in that way that it can advocate
for the user.
So, another thing that declarative content
offers is that is provides semantic understanding
for the user agent.
So, what that means is that the user agent
has a view into what's being asking to rendered
or presented to the use.
I find this example extremely lie lighting
of what I'm talking about.
If we look at the left side, you're seeing
the web.
If given this canvas to render the object
like on the web today, given an XY location,
you can only see the color.
I see a black pixel, a white pixel, a gray
pixel.
But nothing more than that.
But with semantic understanding of what's
actually in the scene, we have a much more
rich understanding of the model the and the
content that we're placing.
So, if you look at the right side, you can
see I'm looking at the windshield.
And it has a material that's class.
And it's transparent.
You can also see things like the tire and
stuff like that.
And so, you can imagine with screenreaders
or accessible or just translating this into
soundbased AR, you can actually talk about
what the user is seeing.
So, you could say I see a van with black tires
and white car metal paint.
So, the next part of the user agent that I'll
talk about is rendering.
So, the user agent is response for rendering
to the browser.
So, modern web rendering emergencies are amazing.
They're fantastic.
That's blank, echo, WebKit, things like that.
When you think about what they asked to do,
it's mostly 2D and it's textbased.
They're fantastic at rendering pages like
the verge at 60 frames per second.
And some of you might know and some of you
might not, but the web already does performant
3D rendering.
That's great and provided to the user through
a Canvas element and uses WebGL to create
those graphics.
What that might look like today is this, this
is not augmented or virtual reality.
But it's just rendering in a web page using
a canvas and WebGL.
So, for the rendering needs of augmented reality,
thinking back to the vision is this complex
composition and layout dynamics of content.
So, we're gonna probably need to build a rendering
engine that can handle that from the ground
up.
Whereas the modern rendering engines were
optimized for 2D.
And so, even though I just said that we probably
want this authorized from the ground up and
that we don't want to use Canvas elements,
we tried it.
So, my team experimented on this internal
prototype, air web view.
It's a set of libraries that enable AR through
native apps and web view.
It's a lightweight browse their you can embed
into a native app.
The technical understanding of what we've
done is that we've web rendered and using
that to do than we have tracking, AR Core
and ARKit.
And we combine that with a natively rendered
camera feed.
Let's look at what that looks like.
You look at the example, we have a stormtrooper
and it's convincingly rendered into the space
around you.
You need to make sure that the content that's
rendered moves at the same time as a native
camera feed.
Because if it's off, it completely breaks
the illusion.
So, we have this transparent web view, it's
rendering the content, and this becomes a
difficult technical problem.
Because if you're familiar, and don't worry
if you're not.
You have a render loop that's running from
the browser.
But then you also have a render loop that's
running natively, and you also have the update
loop for the native tracking.
So, it's figuring out a way to get all of
these things working together in a performant
way.
And the advantages of AR web view is it's
lightweight.
It's only 60 kilobytes added to your app.
It's crossplatform.
So, you write code once and it works on both
iOS and Android.
It's embeddable into native apps and you can
pull down content and code on demand.
And that last part, to highlight the advantages
of that is that you can make changes to this
augmented reality experience that's independent
from your native app code.
You don't have to wait for an app release
to change your AR experience.
So, one use of AR web view in action was at
Google IO this year.
If you were there, you would have seen this
experience that allowed you to orient yourself
once you're on site at the conference.
Using augmented reality, you could see which
way you might want to go next.
And so, this experience is literally just
a web page.
And these white text that say water station
and eats market are just actually HTML elements
styled with 3D transforms.
So, again, AR web view, it's a prototype,
it's internal.
We will a lot of fun and learned a lot with
it.
So, this last aspect of the user agent that
I'll talk about is that the user agent retrieves
content on behalf of the user.
And this part is so fascinating to me.
So, if you think back to this vision of augmented
reality, you're walking down the street.
And you look at a restaurant and it knows
what you want is the menu information.
And it knows what you want is the Instagram
photos.
And so, if I was doing this today on my smartphone,
I would go to the restaurant.
I would see the name.
I would type it into maybe Google search,
who knows.
And then I would access the information that
I wanted.
But what we have with augmented reality is
this fundamental paradigm shift.
Now the user agent is querying on my behalf
and should know what I want to see.
That's very interesting if in a camerafirst
browser environment, the user receives content
rather than querying for it.
That means that the user gets it over the
surfacing.
This is an interesting question off the bat.
We can think about modern questions like echo
chambers and stuff like that.
Manage imagine you're in an augmented reality
immersive world and you don't know when there's
content that you're not seeing.
Or you should have a way to know and have
ways to set preferences on what you do want
to see.
And I think that there is kind of this pessimistic
view of that.
But I think there's a lot of advantages of
having this intermediary between you and the
information.
An example that I like to think
Imagine you're a coffee drinker.
You wake up, you want to wear your AR glasses
on the way to work.
You haven't had your glass of coffee, you
want the bare minimum.
Until you get to the coffee shop, then you
are ready to get the other things coming.
In that way, the user agent having discretion
is an advantage.
And so, as you start to hear these things
about augmented reality and maybe this future
where everybody is wearing headsets.
You might be like me yesterday in Conrad electronics
thinking, that's a lot of cameras.
So, it's true.
A camerafirst future requires a lot of cameras.
And it's not just augmented reality that's
facing these things.
It would be things like selfdriving cars where
they have six censors, eight, a ton of sensors
looking at the world around it as they're
processing.
What that means is we're capturing basic life
everything that happens on the sidewalk.
Anything that someone wearing one of these
headsets can see.
And so, as we try to build towards this augmented
reality feature, we need to have privacy and
surveillance top of mind when thinking about
worldscale AR.
So, at face value, I think one of the first
things you would think about in the context
of privacy is that these cameras are capturing
RGB data about the world around you.
Which is just a picture.
So, what happens with that picture data?
Is your device computing it on device?
Is it going up to the cloud?
Who owns that data on the cloud?
Is it going to your private cloud?
And then when you think about secondary data.
So, that's information that's extracted from
this camera image which is how augmented reality
works.
You can imagine if you're building meshes
around you.
You live in an apartment building with a distinct
statue outside.
You walk out.
Your headset creates a mesh of this statue
and someone could know exactly where that
statue is and locate you.
Even if they don't have the camera data, they
can understand that from the derivative information
that's used for augmented reality.
And what I think, though, is that user user
agents being more powerful is actually an
advantage in this scenario.
Because if we can move that information away
from the developer and closer to a trusted
user agent, that's a positive thing.
But we'll need something like open source
code to actually know that we're being that
we can trust our user agents.
So, to me, augmented reality and the web is
an amazing partnership.
The web will gain a whole new access for understanding
information.
It will be more contextualized.
It will be ergonomic.
And for augmented reality, the web for sure
is an important piece.
It will provide the content and I love the
webby principles that we use today.
I think as we look forward to a future with
augmented reality, we need to keep those webby
principles in line.
If you are interested in using the resources
today, check out the resources.
Look at the model viewer and see if adding
3D models increases use and context to your
information.
And also, start talking to us about the WebXR
device API.
Everyone's opinion matters and it will be
great for the ecosystem overall.
So, to me if the web plus augmented reality
is an open ecosystem of rich, contextualized
information, then I'm excited and I hope that
you all are too.
[ Applause ]